The joe rogan experience.
Right. And is the same. It
will be at a parent parent.
A lot of parents are really lazy and
you watch it happen when they give their
kid an iPad or you know or you know,
put them in front of the computer.
That whole thing just happened
with Elsa Gate, which was you know,
borderline hilarious that parents were
getting trolled into their kids watching
really fucked up like cartoons.
Yeah. Elsie get, I forgot the name.
The name of it. Yeah that was crazy.
We've talked about that a bunch of
times about the babies with the broken
bottles over their head kept
having the same scene play out.
Kids would get drunk
whether they were a kid,
mice or kid docs or they would get drunk.
A bottle would go flying through the air
and hit the baby in the head and blood
would be everywhere. It was, it
was like a baby's nightmare to,
those videos were so
crazy. It was a bunch of
street. David Lynch for sure.
It was a punishment for shitty parents
who weren't watching you know their kids
and what they're putting on their TV.
Cause if you were just paying attention
for a minute, you, I'm saying write it.
You have to stop paying attention for
a couple hours for a kid to get there.
So it was only really shitty parents
that we're dealing with that.
Is that really true?
It's dude,
yet there was no way to like land
on that just by googling Spiderman.
That wasn't the first one that was
coming up. It was, uh, they would,
I think there were like paying to get
into like a loop of certain videos.
Like it was,
it really,
I was obsessed with it for like a week
and I just couldn't stop going on under
that sub reddit page.
And it was freaky dude.
They weren't really radio regular porn.
Yeah, there's a Spiderman
ones and all these, I think
they took some of them down,
but then it gets to this
place where you're like, okay,
are you taking it down because
it's targeting children?
Are you taking it down because you can't
show cartoon babies getting hit in the
head with bottles. Because if
that's what you're saying, boy,
there's a lot of fucking south parks
that you're not going to be able to show.
There's a lot, a lot, a lot of different
things. Yeah. Where's the line?
Because you think this is like creepy
and is luring kids in versus the just the
act of it was a funny,
you know Tim and Eric Sketch and a
cartoon baby got hit in the head with a
bottle. You'd be like, what
the fuck? These guys are
nuts. That's what you'd said.
But you wouldn't be like saying this has
gotta be removed off of Youtube. Yeah,
it's hard to pay attention.
What's the intention of it?
But you could easily say like,
oh well South Park is a cartoon.
So is that appealing to kids?
But I think to Lewis his point that the
solution isn't that this shit needs to
be banned. The solution is just like
let parents know always the solution.
Every single time we talk about Louis,
what was the other one we watched?
Oh father, your father, the two kids.
And it's really just creepy as shit
dude happen. All right, so this guy,
another like one of those like
that the kids are watching that.
If you watch it for a second,
you're like, this is all
pulled it off. It was a dad
and his channel, I'm sorry,
I forget the name of the channel,
but he had his two little girls who were
probably seven and nine years old and
they were doing like just
kind of weird shit dude.
They're like eating chocolate bars and
there'd be chocolate all over their face
and then they'd make weird sounds
and they'd climb up like you know,
stairs and they'd showed from like
behind there butt and it was very fucking
pedophilia. I don't even
know. It was fucked up dude.
And this guy is channel got taken down
and the guy's like doing an interview.
He's like, no dude, whatever.
We also millions of subscribers to the
channel making tons of money paying first
house with this channel. Whoa. And
they shut the whole channel down.
And what did he say when they
interviewed him? I don't know.
I've read some thing when it
was just kinda like, yeah,
we're trying to get our
channel back and you know,
he was just like very innocent. There
was another thing the same. Oh fuck.
I'm on my own time.
I got to go to Vimeo.
Um, but the same when we were talking
about this stuff, there was moms,
they were regular like mom bloggers,
right?
And they bring like their
daughter to Kmart, right?
This is the channel by the way,
terminates toy freaks channel amid broader
crackdown on disturbing kids content.
Okay.
It is very, like what Jay said,
it's a very David Lynch type vibe.
Like you feel like you're
in some nightmare world
where everyone's just acting
not the right human way.
That 8.5 million subscribers,
gold plaques that you have
amongst the top
most 100 most of you channels on youtube.
That's incredible.
Either while pacifiers in their
mouth it, dude, it's fucking bizarre.
You gotta somehow it got somehow
got to that level before.
Can we watch some of this?
Yeah. I can't show it.
We can't show it on TV. Can we watch
it? Is there a way we can not see it?
We're about to get raided. You get
what you figured out. Okay. Yeah.
Don't know what the problem is.
Whenever we put something on youtube
that shouldn't be on youtube,
we get flagged.
Um,
there was like mommy bloggers and they
would like have a video of them and their
daughter going to like the
supermarket and it'd be like 500
views. Yeah, don't do it Jamie. If if
they, I was thinking of Youtube flags,
not planning to see it. Oh, okay. So no
one else could see it on another website.
Okay. Okay. I'm sorry Louis. What?
Okay. So yeah, so then,
and then they do another,
the same mommy blogger would do one called
bath time and she's like bathing her
five year old and it's not anything
like more than her like sitting in the
bathtub.
But those videos were getting millions
of views and then the mom would like
disable the comments and turn off
the thumbs up and the thumbs downs.
So they were just monetizing,
you know,
pedophiles jerking off to their
daughters in a bathtub. And it was,
this is just like a whole subculture that
was happening on youtube that was sort
of just, nobody was really talking about
it and they kind of made it go away.
It wasn't even a big deal.
Cool. So this, I'm watching this, it's
not disturbing and all, it's just dumb.
They just eating weird food and then
and getting like whipped cream and ice
cream and cake and nachos altogether.
Well here's what happens. Babies.
This is really targeted toward babies.
They like the colors.
So what happened?
Like they see these flashing crazy colors.
Them I'm packaging candy and cake and
eating cake and two year olds love the
shit they keep on clicking on it.
But pedophiles are also jerking off to
these girls putting chocolate bananas in
their mouth. That was sort of
the issue. So they got, you know,
the pencil subscribed to whatever
cause the, they want to put
their kid in front of a TV and
have the TV babysit them. Um,
but it was also another big part of
the people who are watching this.
You see the comments and some of the,
sometimes the comments were like encrypted
and like in different languages and
they were using code words and how
they're using that pizza gate yet it's all
connected up.
It's fucking crazy.
If you make a big complaint though about
something you have to draw a conclusion
to, it really makes it seem like you're
the person thinking that you're like,
come on, you don't think that's
hot. Yeah, exactly. Exactly.
You wouldn't want to jerk off to this.
Come on.
We're all jerking off to this then who
didn't jerk off to that a little earlier?
Mitchell that a cheeto with sour cream
on it. I'll check it off to anybody.
You're just in it for the food.
Get these kids out of here or they
have family they didn't notice.
Say what can and can't be on
TV though or on video or on,
you know, when do you say they're
going to want this? But I know right,
but whose day? Right. Cause we've all,
we've all got this weird thing about
free speech because if it wasn't for free
speech we wouldn't be able to do anything.
Wouldn't be able to do podcasts,
wouldn't be able to comedy.
You'd get in trouble for everything.
It's very important to be
able to express your ideas,
but what if those ideas are, what
if you're a pedophile? Like what if?
What about that? Are you allowed to
do pedophile anime? Like how it would,
where's the, where's the line and why? Why
are we able to draw that line? You know,
I draw a Dick Right now when I
will dry deck. Here's the deck.
Now if I say this is a four year
old's Dick. Okay, there you go. Well,
we'll just say the four year old got
a big Dick. He's got a giant bed.
[inaudible] man who put a
four year old pussy around it
too soon.